what do you see on your property on your
ranch
so what what we see brian we're a little
bit
north of the uh ex the
check the river the border with mexico
and what we
end up seeing is we see and and
typically
what we hear about on the news is people
crossing that border
but uh essentially there's another
border that is
um that is about 50 miles to the north
and we call it the interior
check system or the pure checkpoint and
so
once all these people get across the
river they then
now have to make a another journey
across to this
this next um
kind of kind of like a second border
border and you say one of your uh
one of your neighbors found about a
hundred bodies over the years
on their ranch what ages are they what
are they up to
no that's that's correct we've seen uh
bodies uh we don't find
this many it's all based on where you're
geographically located
and how it uh how people travel and and
where you are as to where the bodies are
found but um
we find more like two to three but i
mean i don't know
that's still enough absolutely um some
people are finding
up to you know like like you said a
neighbor of mine has
um been uh finding close to
10 a year wow for the last 10 years so
with these
you say that these are men between the
20 and their 40s
they would never qualify for the first
right now it is right
right now it is uh brian it's not always
that way
uh in fact right now we're seeing hardly
any children or women
because of everything that's going on on
the river
those those people aren't having to to
make this journey
they're being you know they they can
claim asylum
the women and children can and and
they're being bust places
right now uh there's a real kind of a a
little bit more of a dangerous situation
you have just kind of single men
males right coming up and um and you
know it's it's
it's just there's a sense of fear that
exists down here all the time it's it's
a terrible situation it's not fair and
that's why you're looking to try to pass
the law
uh to try to stop this smuggling to put
more teeth in the law for what texas can
do to smugglers
what does that lost sound like what does
it read like
yeah that's right um so it's uh it's
it's a state it's a state law um it's hb
687
and uh we we're real fortunate that we
got a
uh we got a hearing for it uh yesterday
and
what it does is it it basically helps
penalize smugglers and it provides
protections
for uh immigrants and um
you know it it allows our local law
enforcement to do
instead of it it helps him improve
the penalty on gotcha or strengthen the
penalty on trespassing
and um from a state level and it gives
our local law enforcement ability to
to do more with gotcha you know with the
situation
all right we'll look forward to
following about that everyone looks at
the river and the border but there's a
second border and you just
enlighten us on that whit jones thanks
so much
thank you brian have a good day you got
it